the Joe Rogan experience um one things I
wanted to ask you about space is we
always hear stuff about space junk about
satellites and just junk that's floating
around the atmosphere how much of a
concern is that and what could be done
about that stuff it's a huge concern
it's a very very big problem in in in
certain orbits around the earth
low-earth orbit and also at the
geostationary orbits that are very
that's where you could put like
communication satellites and they stay
over one spot of the earth those are
very polluted you know there's a lot of
junk and it is very dangerous and it's
it's a real problem is hard to clean up
over time eventually even even at higher
altitudes it's still a little bit of
atmosphere like individual atoms
eventually that slows you down those
collisions eventually slow you down so
eventually it comes back but it could
take a long long time come back to Earth
you mean yeah it'll come back and he'll
burn up so the most important thing is
don't make any more junk that's like the
best thing we can do and we're getting
much smarter they get SpaceX we take our
second stages and all of our NASA
missions and after after we it's
accomplished its mission we keep enough
gas in the tank to burn the engine one
more time and bring it back in one piece
so it doesn't blow up into smithereens
and cause more junk whenever we do
anti-satellite test though China did one
relatively recently and we've done them
in the past those are like the worst
because they create giant clouds of junk
and and we have to still we still have
to live with that is there any concepts
on the table for how to do that stuff
out there's some ideas of you know using
lasers that lays the things and and and
and and make subtle changes to their
trajectories and orbits but it's all
that all the technical solutions are
challenging and expensive so I don't
know of any one idea that's gonna like
just solve this problem easily because
we've seen the map of the earth and all
the different satellites that orbit it
now and all the different jump pieces of
junk that have been identified it's
crazy yeah the amount of stuff and it
seems like nobody kind of thought it
through they just sort of did it and
left the junk up there
that's what humans do man I mean like
we've been dumping stuff in the oceans
forever yeah and not really giving much
thought to it and now we're finding
giant gyros of plastic or then you know
yeah so yeah we tend to not really react
until it's a really big problem but it's
a big problem and and when I did my
first spacewalk one of the things we had
to do was we had to bring in this handle
they were going to use on a subsequent
spacewalk it was like it was we call it
D handle it's just basically a half-inch
piece of aluminum around like like this
that you can attach to something then
carry things so they had this big chunk
of aluminum and we brought it inside of
my spacewalk partner Rick looked at the
thing when we came inside to saw a hole
shot straight through it it's like about
a millimeter in diameter it's really
small but it went right through this
half-inch thick solid aluminum and he
looked at that and he said man if that
hit one of us and he didn't have to
finish that statement because if this
stuff is moving generally speaking about
10 kilometers per second so that's like
roughly 10 times as fast as a rifle
bullet so something like that hits you
it could be a Fleck of paint hitting you
at that velocity in the hitch in the
suit you're in a hundred percent oxygen
environment and you're just gonna flame
up I mean you're gonna instantly combust
it's gonna be a really a bad day so he
didn't have to like you said you know
when he said that he didn't have to
finish it and we both looked at it and
then I looked at him and said yeah but
you're six foot four so statistically
it's gonna hit you more object and
beside that was kind of behind you most
of the way out there but it'd probably
go right through him and right through
you to hit probably him like that's
what's so crazy about is there's so much
of that stuff up there I'm always
wondering like why doesn't it hit the
space station what it does is a couple
times I was inside the space station I
heard us take a hit whoa but just but so
I heard the ping but fortune I didn't
hear the ping fall but a change yeah so
that ping is probably something bouncing
off something or going through something
so the station has shielding it's called
whipple shielding and it's basically a
piece of
of a wall a thin piece of metal that
stands off from the hull so the thin
piece of metal is never gonna stop this
thing but it when it hits at that hyper
velocity it breaks up into lots of
little tiny pieces and it's almost like
a fluid at that point it's like these
like it's like it like almost a cloud of
dust and then when it hits the hull
those individual pieces don't penetrate
hmm so it just it just shatters it and
that what that works what if it hits
that window it has hit the shuttle
window you know we've it has multiple
panes and it's really really strong but
we came home with big it looks like like
when a rock gets kicked up and it takes
really yeah we've we've seen that yeah
wow that's a little scary Jesus Christ a
little chip what about micro meteors and
things along those lines
well depending on where you are so in in
Earth orbit there's much more of manmade
junk than there are micro meteorites but
there are those too when you get out
away from Earth orbit like if we're
gonna go back to the moon then there's
no more human-made junk but there is
those micro meteorites are still out
there and that they can do the same kind
of damage but there's a lot fewer of
them the density of those things is a
lot less than what you experience so
it's if you go to Mars I'd worry about
the radiation first and then the micro
meteoroids I like down the list it just
seems to so many things to think about
yeah
[Applause]